It turns out, consistency does matter,
and here's how.
Let's say that in program order,
two cores do this.
The first core is going to
store a 1 into location D, and
then store a 1 into location F.
Let's say that D and
F are both 0 initially.
The second core loads F into R1 and
then loads D into R2.
And let's say that now we
print the registers R1 and R2.
Note that we can have an out of order
processor that reorders loads and
stores.
So in execution order, core 1
might still be doing the stores in
the same order, but core 2 decides
to reorder these two loads.
Note that in a uniprocessor,
reordering of loads,
if this core is not writing to these
locations, if perfectly okay, and
in fact, even in a multi-processor,
most of the time it's okay.
Now, let's look at what's possible
to get in R1 and R2 after this.
In program order, these two loads on
core 2 might execute before these
two stores in core 1, so
we can get R1 and R2 are 0.
Here, these two loads in Core 2,
although they've been reordered,
can still happen before
Core 1 gets to store.
So we can get the same thing.
These two loads can happen
after the two stores.
So we can get 1 in both registers here.
In execution order, even if we re-order
them, they can execute after the stores.
So we can get 1 in both of them.
In the program order,
if these two happen like this,
in between the two stores,
we can get R1, when we load,
it's still loading the 0 here, but R2,
when we load, is already loading the 1.
The same thing can happen here.
If these two loads are in between
the stores, then R1 is going to be 0
because it comes before this, and R2 is
going to be 1 because it happens here.
And now it gets interesting.
We have seen that there are these three
possibilities, so the question is, but
can we get R1 to be 1 while R2 is 0?
And in the program order,
if we consider that, it's not possible.
R1 being 1 means that
when we read F we read 1.
That means that this load has
to come after this store.
If that happens, then this load
has to be after this load too.
So pretty much, if we execute this here,
then this has to be here,
and that means that if we read one 1
from F, we will read 1 from D as well.
So the R1 equals 1, R2 equals 0
cannot happen in program order.
But here R1 equals 1 means that
this load needs to be here.
And we can get a 0 in R2
if this load comes here.
So if we put the stores in between the
loads in the execution order like this,
we will get a situation that was not
possible in the original program order.
So the programmer might have expected
that this code can never result in this,
but in an out of order processor
execution on each core, it can.
And note that this doesn't
violate coherence at all.
In all cases, a load and
the store obeyed coherence.
But do we really care about that?
Sure.
For
some obscure orderings this can happen,
do we really care?
When does it really matter that
this doesn't happen and it does?